here's a peek at what guests had to say
after the show okay we're back here on
the Internet is there a secret governor
to democratic success in the red states
is our first question you got to be more
likeable than the Republican I tell you
one guess you have a personality but
here's one thing the Democrats need
what's that all about if a Democrat if a
Democrat is good with money you can't
beat them because the middle part of
America believes that there ought to be
a safety net for the disabled for the
elderly they believe in public education
and Republicans are always talking well
you know we're not going to spend that
much money on those things but if you're
a Democrat who can cut costs and deliver
those programs build budget surpluses
and still cut taxes they can't be and is
for guns and energy well that helps to
serve any democratic right is there
solid evidence dr. Lustig that GMOs
affects kids health not at the moment
not at the moment at the moment but
we're waiting uh the data on GMOs is so
sparse bottom line is only the companies
that make them could do the studies and
I don't want to and that's how they slid
prop 37 under the wire if you can't
trust Monsanto who can you trust people
come on Kellyanne Conway since social
issues like gay marriage in marijuana
are becoming more widely accepted does
the GOP need to adjust the GOP
individual candidates need to be who
they are we exact we actually have a
diverse viewpoint on those issues
including abortion and if anybody
including you governor can name five
prominent pro-life female Democrats in
this country I'll give you the rest of
my time because they've all been driven
out of the party at least we have
pro-choice Republicans we have pro-life
Republicans we have Republicans who are
for gay marriage every pelicans bird
with the pro-choice Republican Susan
Collins of me Lisa Murkowski of Alaska
two female senators Christy Whitman um
who is the Governor of New Jersey long
time ago what's the difference but there
are no probe but there are no probably
not any party
I am Howard's app it's actually not true
that they're they're pro-life
there are seven pro-life democrats in
the federal Congress governor who have
really who run is who run as federal dam
who run is pro-life democrats who get
money and they're all men Bob Casey jr.
and gerrymandered districts in the house
don't need to move as much because
they're much more homogeneous and that's
a big problem we have but I read in the
climate study that 6% of scientists are
Republican is that a problem problem for
what six percent of well I mean
Republicans are scientists are 66
percent of scientists are repellent of
scientists on this issue are probably
what are you talking about Republicans
are very science but we are pros I mean
you guys do something and it's it's so
untoward if not Irish if I pay which is
just sort of make everybody think the
same in the Republican Party and I'm
trying to show you where there's
diversity of viewpoint I mean the
governor on paper on surface position
sounds very public at least he's welcome
as a conservative Democrat his party but
if you are so balloons of scientists
what science why do you look at a
sonogram of a five month old baby and
deny what you see if you're so fond of
such denying what we see most of the
Democratic Party
what are they denying what are they
gonna get denying that that's a human
life we're not denying you know when the
Supreme Court says first of all first of
all that's not crazy what what a 5-month
okay here's well here's why there's a
debate about this issue which I am
somewhat sympathetic to I don't think
that the abortion debate is like the
homosexuality debate because
homosexuality is real okay a five month
old sonogram is something that is
becoming undeniably human life and is
also undeniably not yet I'm deny it
they're not denying that it is it is on
its way to becoming a human life is they
do there plenty of them but they're not
denying that but I think the court the
fundamental question here is if the
Republicans want to actually make make
progress at the national level and both
in the Senate and
in
Presidency the party is going to have to
adapt but that's not going to change the
viability of the vast majority
republican candidates in the house and
it's not going to change where a lot of
the money's going to the Republican
campaigns either that's not going to get
change any time soon all right David D
asked Kevin Nealon how do you feel about
Al Franken becoming the first comedian
senator and would you support a move to
on the future to become the first
comedian president a president be
president or hey I know that's it's
unclear it's just some damn comedian
well I think al Franks is doing a great
job he is doing yeah yeah when he I've
seen some of the sketches he was able to
get on an SNL so I know he'll be able to
pass them it'll work with him yeah no
but I think he's great he's really uh
and and he's really kept his head down
and not Vanessa
he's been the opposite of a publicity
monger because you know everybody else
they have to kind of warm up their image
he was like woo I was terrible so I got
a clump I like we don't say yeah yeah
Park the punchline right it's been on
he's done a terrific job at that okay
Ellie you seem to be outnumbered by
everybody here do you want me to come on
your side yes that a gender thing or an
ideology bring that Harlem coming all
right oh yeah I'll bite Al Franken was
for the sugar lobby because Minnesota
makes a whole lot of beet sugar and
actually voted against obesity uh-oh
there you go there you go oh and no one
is in my talks I don't want no one is
but that in fact the Democrats and
Republicans are both in the pockets of
course yeah and and who was more in the
pocket of Monsanto than Hillary Clinton
and and by the way let's not just stop
at sugar its corn syrup its corn syrup
every state that grows corn that is true
but yeah just from the maple syrup just
remember
but the dirtiest four-letter word in the
English language is Iowa right because
that's where the first primary is named
Dean is hijos asses right indeed but
also I didn't get to that in the
discussion
it's very devious the way they put on
the ingredients of a package so many
different words that all mean sugar in
dextrose and sucrose and glucose and
this syrup and that's their very own
purpose right very on purpose out there
do you think yogurt is healthy what do
you think yeah well if it's unsweetened
goat yogurt everyone everywhere
everywhere in the world
it's a diet staple every only in America
is it a desert and how come something
called evaporated cane juice what do you
think of that right what happens when
you evaporate cane juice you get yeah
indeed yeah so if if a compound has
toxin a and an antidote B you think it
won't kill you but I thought without
Chobani was changing our life now but
you can get so excited it is changing
our life it's taking a whole lot of
money and there is a case in the
California state courts right now of
asking about the mislabelling of Chobani
yogurt because of evaporated cane juice
means will help us all out tell us what
to look for when we pick up a yogurt in
the grocery store what do we want to see
or what do we not want to see when you
buy goat and nothing bud goat yogurt
absolutely that's right if it's plain
it's fine if it's plain it's fine that's
right that's the answer okay yeah put
some fruit enjoy I was gonna pass out
Milk Duds to the crowd I am obviously
made a big mistake okay
did the West misunderstand the Arab
Spring mistaking populism for something
else by the way this militia group
operation american spring they took
their inspiration they said if it worked
in egypt why can't it work in america
obviously they should need operation
read the paper because it
do not really work that rowing they do
they did mistake it they thought that
the Egyptians all look like us on the
square they they're pretty they speak
some speak English and they're going to
engage in democracy they never they
never removed the military and so there
wasn't a real revolution and therefore
there couldn't have been a real coup yes
they got rid of this the head of the
Muslim Brotherhood but he never actually
ran the country and we didn't understand
that okay gotta go
thank you very much everybody you're a
terrific crowd Real Time with Bill Maher
ask Bill and his guesses your questions
right after the show
at HBO calm or on Twitter